he is Brian Wynn worst of the worldwide
leader how are you Brian hi rich how
would you answer the poll question to
start off with a well I mean what a
weekend it was how would you answer
what's the most surprising I'm not sure
I've seen a more difficult shot
then what Kawhi Leonard hit yesterday
because yes was at the buzzer but I
think you have to compute in that there
was a 7-foot two guy who was absolutely
blanketed on top of him and there are
some some incredible images that were
taken by great photographers from all
different angles and you can see Joe L&B
was way off of his feet one of the
reasons why it bounced around the rim
like it did was because Kawhi had to
shoot the ball almost directly straight
up into the air just to get the shot off
I would love to know how high that ball
actually when I was probably around 18
17 18 feet and so the degree of
difficulty of even getting the shot off
much less having to get in one of the
most amazing shots I think you'll ever
see we know when you include the stakes
of course but the actual ability to him
to make that shot just amazing I know
you're comparing things that happen in
less in a slice of a moment to decisions
that will be big over the next few years
head coaching hire it's not really an
apples apples comparison but I'll always
remember that well in terms of this shot
to him he talked about with Kevin Harlan
who called it on on TNT Brian that what
was hanging on the rim potentially is
kawazu Chur and also the future Brett
Brown and what the the Sixers are going
to do do you think that the ball
dropping there does actually affect it
or cement what might happen later on
this summer court more times the ball
hit the rim four times I would like to
believe that a single shot doesn't
determine people's futures of decisions
and the thing about it is is that Kawhi
does not articulate how he's feeling or
thinking like Kyrie does like Kevin
Durant does so we're really all just
left guessing so the answer I can tell
you is I don't know I don't know what it
meant for Kawhi I know that I've never
seen him have that outpouring of emotion
and I've been there on the floor when
he's won a championship and was named
Finals MVP and I've never seen him react
that way that was also I think one of
the basic things I'll always remember is
the way he reacted that was years of you
know I don't know if he's ever erected
to anything like that does that mean
that if he wants to in Toronto I don't
know I mean that's that's the difficulty
of the entire train the trade became a
humongous gamble because there was no
way for you to know and no way for you
to say here's the target we're trying to
hit here's the finish line we were
trying to hit it was completely nebulous
so it's a gamble I think it's a gamble
that for the Raptors has paid off
because they have gotten this chance
they've got their first real chance at
winning a championship they've got a
real chance in this series they're
probably going to have if not the best
player he's 1a and 1b with Yanis and
that's not something they've had before
and that's why they did well then what's
your best guess about what happens in
the aftermath with Philadelphia and the
Sixers in there coach in the process etc
right I mean I saw the report from the
New York Times over the weekend that if
they don't win the series that he is a
danger of being fired again I would say
if the ball doesn't go in and they went
in overtime does that mean he's a good
coach and if it did go and he's not a
good coach you know again I would hope
that it wouldn't be determined by one
game what I would tell you is this the
big decisions that the Sixers have are
not necessarily the way to the coach
they guys I wasn't there keeping Jimmy
Butler they gotta decide whether they're
gonna extend Ben Simmons to a max which
he is eligible for this summer they
gotta decide are they gonna give Tobias
Harris five years so they're gonna keep
JJ record are they gonna spend four
hundred million dollars on a team that
didn't make it out of the second run
because that's what this would be when
you include the money that they already
have committed out there that to me is a
real big decision yes you know if you
think you can get a better coach and one
of the issues that Bret Braun had was
you know sort of getting these guys all
online and all to play along the same
way and and to find a to find a lineup
in a system that would take advantage of
their various talented guys I suppose
maybe they said there's a better guy out
there to do it but if there is I hope
they know who they're gonna fire I'm
sorry who they're going to hire before
they fire because if you just fire but
then just start this
process and think that you're going to
get a better coach I think that's a
pretty big deal
Brian win worst of ESPN in the Honda
inside a report here on the Rich Eisen
show let's talk about the aftermath of
the Warriors and and the Rocket series
first things first
what's Durant status for the Western
Conference Finals best you can tell us
we're talking right now Brian yeah I
think they are hoping that he will come
back at some point now he has had cast
injuries twice in the last three years
and both times he missed a week but this
calf injury
I believe I mean I can't say for certain
I don't have the MRIs I'm not you know a
specialist but from what I understand
it's a little bit more serious than
those other two injuries were one of the
things that happened here rich I was
playing 45 minutes a game I think he was
extending himself a little bit too much
so I would be surprised if he plays
tomorrow I mean I don't know for sure we
don't have an update just yet but I
would expect him to come back some
points in this series which means that
the Blazers you know if they're gonna
have a shot to get ahead and try to get
home court advantage it's probably going
to be today or Thursday would either
Durant doesn't play or is coming back
into somewhat limited and then in terms
of the concept that we just had in the
the Raptors Sixers series a lot away a
playoff result might affect a July first
decision or an offseason decision the
fact that the old-school Warriors the
pre Durant Warriors came to the rescue
in the injured Durant warriors moment
how does that affect everything from
draymond and klay I know the ownership
said that the splash brothers are going
to stay put
Durant how does that affect everything
in their mind Brian it's very it's a
very unusual situation rich so I was at
the game in Houston I was in the
Warriors locker room their level of
celebration was just below popping the
champagne they were so proud of that
victory chill a cup who's their owner
told me that it was maybe one of the
biggest victories in his nine years as
owner and by the way they were twice
that three trophies and at least some
part of that was because was without
Durant and I don't think it was in a way
to like sort of send a message to him or
anything
because his uniform was hanging in the
locker they were facetiming him and
texting him and sending him photos he
was as involved in the in the
celebration as you can be virtually in
2019 but I think it they all know that
Durant is there's a chance that he's
gonna leave is it 19 percent is at 56% I
don't know I mean I could throw some
number at you that could sound good for
next three minutes but would just be
bogus and bull but obviously everybody
knows there's a chance he's walking and
so some element of that celebration and
embracing that victory was the reality
that they may be without Durant next
year it was kind of a vindication not
only to themselves in that moment but
that they are still the great team that
won the titles before Durant got there I
can't quantify it I can't explain it I'm
not on the team I'm not draymond Green I
can't say exactly how he felt but
observing it there was no doubt that
that was a piece and part of what was
going on in that moment when they had a
phenomenal with all things considered
well and then the Rockets I mean the
hardening after the game saying he knows
what the needs to be done to beat the
Warriors but he's gonna keep it to
himself was one of those moments where I
just shake my head again I I'm not there
every day I don't follow him in terms of
meeting him and chat with him the day-in
day-out stuff and I look the rest the
Rockets see my we've had Morrie on the
show PJ Tucker spills his guts out on
the floor unlike many players in the NBA
I love watching him how in the world do
you what are the Rockets do from here
because it doesn't seem like if you
can't beat him now you're never gonna
beat him Brian well the difficulty is I
mmm I question whether their ownership
is willing to go to the wall they did
not spend their mid-level exception this
year to add to that team you know if you
don't want to find Trevor Ariza at a 15
million dollar deal you don't evaluate
him it's worth that much I mean I I
can't really dispute that the other guy
that they got you know criticized for
letting him go was lupa Babu say he
missed the entire season with a knee
injury
but they didn't spend the mid-level
exception and they they went to all
sorts of lengths during the season to
get under the luxury tax including
training away their first-round pick
this year now again I'm not going to sit
here and tell you the oath they had the
26 pick but they're going to get a
player's it's good
take that past the Warriors but what is
the priority is that priority - when at
the highest level or is the priority to
be as competitive as possible and stay
under the luxury tax Tillman for Tina
was on the jump on Friday I asked him
essentially this direct question and he
dodged it you know and I understand why
- because it's an uncomfortable question
and that to me is a major factor about
where this organization is going is
Tillman for Tina gonna clear them to
spend the money that they need to spend
now I'm not gonna sit there and tell a
guy who just paid two billion dollars
fifteen that he has to spend money into
a losing situation but if you're gonna
evaluate whether Rockets are going
forward they've overpaid Chris Paul he's
clearly on the downside of this failure
and the question is is he gonna do what
needs to be done to try to keep
supporting that roster until you answer
that question I'm not so sure that I can
give a fair evaluation of where the team
it last question for you last subject in
this Honda inside a report with you
Brian win horse and you being the author
of a New York Times bestseller LeBron
Inc the making of a billion billionaire
dollar athlete and by the way
congratulations on that your perfect
person asked and again your column on it
was exemplary as usual
on the hiring of Vogel and Jason Kidd
here and how it's gonna work with LeBron
I'll give you the floor on how you think
this is gonna go
don't thank you for the kind words but
you know first level is a quality coach
I don't think he's a needle mover I
would tell you that if it was just Frank
Vogel being hired I was in and that was
what you were asking me about it look
well she wasn't their first or second
choice but he's an experienced coach
he's one and he's been able to succeed
in a difficult situation before I go
back to when he took over at midseason
with the Pacers and he completely
transformed that team within six months
and I gave him a lot of credit for that
so I would say you know he's got a fair
shot LeBron has spoken highly of him in
the past but he has probably had immense
respect for he's not a championship
coach didn't play in the league but you
know he's got a fighting chance but you
add the Jason Kidd factor rich and it's
like putting weights around his ankles
because even if LeBron doesn't mean -
he's going to gravitate towards the Hall
of Fame point guard who he could peel it
against it has immense respect for who
he played alongside in the 2008 Olympics
which was one of the most important
developmental moments of his career it
turned changed how he operates as a
leader playing alongside Jason Kidd that
summer there is no way that he could
possibly have the same respect profile
for Frank bold as he does Jason Kidd and
that's not a character flaw that's just
a reality and for the Lakers to do that
to put him in a situation where it's
going to be so much more difficult to
succeed and what we're gonna watch it of
course we're gonna what happens if you
know the Laker start next season one in
four and during that game LeBron is
caught in the huddle talking with Jason
Kidd it could be anybody he's talking
huddle with but it's going to be
magnified I just don't think that they
put Frank Vogel in the best position to
be successful and on the bigger picture
if they operate their coaching starts
like this or they go to their third or
fourth choice and they hire a guy that
they hadn't even formally interviewed
until the day before they hire him what
does that say about what their plan for
their draft is what is that say for what
their plan for their free agency is
because as I've said I may have said
this to you I don't care if they got Red
Auerbach back from the beyond until they
fix this roster the coach is secondary
you know the coach is important but you
know this roster can't win
and so III I'm you know the most
important person is offseason is Rob
pálinka and Jeanie buss it's not Frank
Vogel so you know the Lakers have an
opportunity because they have caps base
because people want to play in LA they
have a more of a grace period at a
margin prayer than a place like Memphis
or a place like Milwaukee but I my faith
in them executing and making smart
decisions is is very low especially
after watching others coach Brian great
stuff has always really appreciated
always enjoy the chats and we'll chat
down I think the way you started our
conversation was was spot-on this was
the I said I started to show best
weekend of playoff basketball or the
NBA's had maybe ever and I know that
that's a that might be an exaggeration
but from everything that we just did
we'd even hit the belied stuff because I
know we've talked about so much but what
a weekend that's right thanks for the
chat we'll chat soon you got it Bronwyn
Horst at window Horst ESPN for more of
the rich
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app